[Musique]
thierry coville bonjour oui bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
le disait un hier le président iranien a
demandé aux européens de faire plier
washington et a exclu toute réunion
entre l'iran et les états unis à vienne
finalement comment est ce que vont
s'organiser les échanges aujourd'hui
pourquoi les européens doivent-ils avoir
le rôle de médiateur est pas tout
simplement une discussion directe
sourire on en est qu'au début donc c'est
vraiment quand il ya un premier pas
positif mais c'est le premier pas je
crois que c'est la première réunion dans
le cadre officiel de l'accord sur le
nucléaire de 2015 ou iraniens et
américains seront côte à côte
donc si vous voulez c'est un premier pas
positif mais dont tout le monde sait que
l'objectif c'est le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord donc je pense
que la grande question c'est la
coordination à la fois de la levée des
sanctions américaines et du côté iranien
de d'annuler toutes les mesures qu'ils
ont prises depuis juin 2019 de sortie
dans l'accord pourquoi les européens on
va dire il ya la relation qui revient
traditionnelle entre les européens et
les américains donc moi je pense que
c'est un peu de la forme c'est les
américains se coordonnent beaucoup avec
les européens qui sont leurs alliés pour
organiser ce retour progressif des états
unis dont les corps alors pourquoi les
états unis ont accepté de participer à
partir d'aujourd'hui à ces discussions
pourquoi le nouveau président joe biden
cherche à renouer avec téhéran
alors ça c'est la suite logique quand
même de ce qu'il a annoncé dans sa
campagne présidentielle il a dit que si
la sortie des états dits dans l'accord
2015 en mai 2018 était une erreur que la
politique de pression maximale de trêve
n'avait donné aucun résultat
donc logiquement et l'a annoncé il
annoncé que les états unis voulaient
revenir dans l'accord alors il y avait
plein d'incertitudes moi je pense que le
principal problème c'était vis-à-vis du
contexte de politique intérieure
américain visait donc on sait qu'il ya
pas mal de même de démocrates et de
républicains qui reste comme assez
opposé à vicky celui d'iran vous avez
également le
lobbying de l'arabie séoudite d'israël
donc le prêtre c'était comment faire
passer si vous laisse ce retour des
etats-unis dans la corde ça a pris du
temps mais là on y ajoute il vraiment je
pense que là c'est cette réunion c'est
comment organiser le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord par joly dit la
grande question c'est d'un côté la levée
progressive des sanctions américaines
prises par depuis mai 2018 par donald
trump et de l'autre côté
en parallèle si vous voulez le retour de
l'iran dans l'accord de 2015 et qui est
ce qu a le plus intérêt à voir les états
unis réintégrer l'accord les américains
eux mêmes ou bien l'iran j'ai envie de
vous dire ce que j'ai déjà dit des
retraites c'est le droit quand même
international je dirais donc elle toute
la communauté
enfin devenir le monde entier comment
dire le système international a intérêt
que cet accord soit revitaliser parce
que cet accord a été validé ont été
signés en juillet 2015 a été validé par
une résolution des nations unies les
nations unies ils luttent efficacement
contre le risque de prolifération
nucléaire au moyen orient l'iran
respecté l'accord rappelons le quand
même rame et 2018 donc c'est le droit
international et le fait que les etats
unis soient sortis de l'accord en mai
2010huit c'était ça crée beaucoup
d'instabilité moyen orient l'iran
commencé à s'affranchir de l'accord il
voulait donc éventuellement aller vers
la bombe nucléaire donc je veux dire
toute la communauté internationale à
l'intérêt à ce retour accord alors pour
répondre à votre question je pense les
l'iran est dans une situation de crise
économique grave dont ils ont intérêt
effectivement à ce que les sanctions se
relever mais c'est une erreur et je
pense que joe biden l'a compris de ceux
de de penser que simplement avec les
sanctions on va faire tout ce qu'on veut
avec lyon du côté américain je pense
qu'ils comprennent aussi que ils ont des
projets de se désengager de la région
notamment s'est d'ailleurs déjà
désengagé d'afghanistan c'est pas le
moment de faire monter les tensions à
mes clients et à ce que les les la
position des sanctions contre contre
l'iran ont pu ralentir le développement
du programme nucléaire iranien justement
est au contraire de ce que je vous
disais c'est là le
comment dire un des problèmes de la
politique de pression maximale de bonne
trempe c'est en mettant toutes ces
sanctions contre l'iran oui l'économie
iranienne s'est effondré mais qu'est ce
que donnerait de l'irak ont eu
logiquement disant écoutez si c'est
comme ça l'accord ne tient plus donc
nous rend sort progressivement de
l'accord donc les rangs a commencé à
enrichir à 20% l'uranium d'eau à 90%
c'est quand même le niveau militaire et
il ya déjà en iran qui demandent de
sortir du traité de non-prolifération
disons peut pas compter sur les sur les
occidentaux peut pas compter sur les
américains le niveau de méfiance
vis-à-vis des etats-unis est monté au
maximum en iran donc la politique de
pression maximum a conduit l'iran à
s'affranchir de cet accord jeudi qu'ils
étaient bons pour la lutte contre la
prolifération nucléaire et la stabilité
régionale au moyen-orient en tout cas
l'approché des patates ce seront des
pourparlers directs entre washington et
téhéran on peut s'y attendre dans
combien de temps je suis pas sûr si
voulez ça ça va arriver
j'ai l'impression on revit un peu ce
qu'on a vécu rappelez vous avant les
négociants 2013 d'ailleurs est ce que
les états unis et l'iran n'ont pas
commencé déjà à discuter ensemble
personnes enseignants parce que ce
disque est très important vis-à-vis du
droit international c'est quand même que
officiellement les états unis reviennent
dans l'accord de 2015 que les sanctions
liées à cette sortie des années de lagor
soit annulé et donc si vous voulez être
là je veux dire ce serait une première
étape là on verra effectivement je pense
qu'à partir de là sans doute les états
unis et les rangs pourront discuter
d'autres sujets mais dans le futur de
ceux qui fâchent comme le point
balistique iranien la politique
régionale de l'iran mais la première
étape très importante c'est vraiment le
retour on va dire officialiser des états
unis dans la corne 2015 merci beaucoup
thierry coville pour votre éclairage ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes chercheur
à l'iris spécialiste de l'iran